there is no bottom to the slippery slope
that we are on in this country
when it comes to crime when it comes to
the justice system when it comes to
especially
weird sex stuff
we've we've been thinking that we're at
the bottom of the slippery slope since
what the 90s and it just keeps we just
keep on slipping
there's a story now
out of a north carolina public preschool
there's a public school that has
preschool as part of it the preschool
teacher was just taught
indoctrinate or was just caught rather
indoctrinating kids into lgbt lmnop
ideology
how how is this even possible to
indoctrinate a third a three-year-old or
a four-year-old into lgbt well the
teacher was teaching his students
colors
colors and then
was caught
i'm sorry it was a woman that makes it
slightly less creepy she was then caught
using the lgbt flag to teach the
students colors the cards that were used
in this lesson are created by this
company by us box which made sets of
flashcards showcasing non-binary and
transgender animals gender neutral
nursery rhymes and a blackness
collection the company i'm just reading
it this is right from the daily mail the
company was created by two women who
said they were inspired by the murder of
george floyd
what
that checks every wokeness box the
company
because of
because of george floyd
dying while he had a toxic a lethal dose
of fentanyl in his system resisting
arrest
he died
and then that was called a racist murder
because of that they were inspired to
make gay flash cards
to teach three-year-olds about
transgenderism in public schools does
that does that do you follow that logic
in a way i kind of do
the logic is
all of the traditional standards of our
society are bad we need to get rid of
all of them
that's that's the logic
in marx's words it's the ruthless
criticism of all that exists and it's on
race and it's on justice and it's on
drugs and it's on crime and it's on sex
and it's on education and it's on
everything
and the left is going to tell you there
is no there is no lgbt indoctrination in
preschool
take off your tinfoil hat you crazy
conspiracy theorist in public preschool
no
no wacko okay alex jones uh no your
taxpayer dollars are not going to
indoctrinate three-year-olds into lgbt
and transgenderism and it's good that
they are
what was that last part no i said that
your taxpayer dollars are not no i said
after that part i said oh it's good that
they are
it's good
it's good that we are doing exactly what
you're accusing us of doing
i mention it just to remind you this
stuff actually is happening don't let
them gaslight you
and it's not gonna stop at three it's
not gonna stop at three we used to say
it's not going to stop in college it's
not going to stop in high school not
going to stop in middle school not going
to stop in elementary school not going
to stop at preschool it's going to go
you're going to get this stuff in vitro
pretty soon okay
you're going to get this stuff for
one-year-olds
baby's first
monkey box party or something that's
going to be that'll be like a little a
little
uh mobile that they'll have over their
crib and it'll be all sorts of
sexual icons and rainbows and all sorts
of creepy stuff that's what you're gonna
get okay because because
the left's total revolution on all
aspects of society demand it they're
gonna deny it the whole time and as
they're denying it they're gonna tell
you that it's good that it's happening
father
is taken to tick tock
to ask for your help
it's hard raising a kid today
the economy is not great
inflation's through the roof
and this dad is he's suddenly realized
it's really hard to pay
for his child's transgender surgery
i'm raising money to help fund my son's
transition related costs
i'm sharing this with his permission
um basically we already have a diagnosis
of gender dysphoria for him
um we have gotten his blood work done
and we need to start him on puberty
blockers as soon as possible
now i personally i didn't i transitioned
later so i wasn't familiar with how
puberty blockers worked
um basically
my insurance doesn't cover this
which is wonderful right
so
this guy i assume it's a guy
i don't know these days if he's
promoting transgenderism he might really
be a chick who took a bunch of drugs i
don't know it's really hard to tell
he's kind of just amorphous and he's got
weird colored hair and he's got a nose
ring and his voice is a little odd and
it whatever he is or she is
he is is promoting transgenderism for
her for his kid see how confusing it is
for his kid and
he wants you to pay for that
how come
all the transgender kids
seem to come from these weirdo psycho
pervert parents isn't that kind of weird
what are the odds i don't i'm this is
not data i'm just using anecdotes here
but i know i know lots of people look i
come from new york i lived in california
i come from very liberal backgrounds
i
have multiple friends who have struggled
with sexual confusion transgenderism
also and i notice they never seem to
come from normal families
they always seem to come from extremely
dysfunctional families and from
parents with lots of disorders isn't
that weird
because we're told that transgenderism
is just a totally natural thing it can
happen to anyone it's biological it's it
comes from your innermost truest self
and yet
the normal families never seem to
produce i'm not saying never i'm not
saying never never but i'm saying it's
so exceedingly rare and it's so
increasingly common
with
dysfunctional weirdo pervert dads like
this guy who's trying to mutilate his
child's body
how did he get the child i don't know i
don't know these days you can get a
child all sorts of ways apparently
the only way that's discouraged is the
old-fashioned way but you can who knows
who knows what this kind of family
situation is and he's saying yeah i
really want to put my kid on puberty
blockers cross-sex hormones mutilate my
poor little kid's body
because he
he totally
has this condition it's not just me
projecting it onto my kid
even though kids just totally absorb
what whatever their parents say and do
and that this is why you this is why you
got to watch your language around kids
because you know the kids are like
sponges and they're absorbing everything
this is why you've got to watch your
behavior because kids are modeling their
behavior after your behavior
so the more dysfunction you get in the
family the more dysfunction you're going
to get through society i saw someone
responding
to one of these incidents they said you
know listen
you can't legislate family okay
listen get your politics out of my
family how dare you what do you what
does that mean
you sometimes hear people say you can't
legislate morality i don't know what
that means
you can't legislate culture i don't know
what that means you can't legislate
family what does that mean what do you
think laws permitting no fault divorce
are
that's legislating family that's going
in the political system and saying this
is what family is going to look like now
what do you think obergefell was
the obergefell decision that that
redefined marriage
not even that long ago what was it about
seven years ago redefined marriage to
include monogamous same-sex unions what
do you think that was that was
legislating family that was culture
being downstream of politics
and not even a majority of the people it
wasn't it wasn't democracy whenever gay
marriage
quote unquote was put up for a vote it
was shot down in california it was shot
down prop 8 it was shot down
and then the judges go in and they say
no we're going to we're going to change
that we
the the self-styled aristocracy not much
of an aristocracy if you ask me we're
going to redefine all these basic things
you're seeing this now
play out this religion
of leftism which is especially concerned
on the sexual front with lgbt but you're
seeing this religion play out throughout
the schools
it's not just the pre-k teacher who got
caught using gay flash cards with their
three-year-olds
you are now seeing whole schools
that are dedicated
to lgbtism
and by the way you're seeing straight
kids move into these schools because
sometimes those schools have better
academics magic city acceptance academy
is a grade 6 through 12 public school
designed to cater to lgbt students in
alabama
i know i did a double take when i heard
that too a lot of things that i didn't
expect but this apparently exists in
alabama and then the craziest part is
you've got
straight kids moving into that school
because the public schools are no good
so they're moving into a school which
offers quote a brave learning
environment and lgbtq affirming culture
for
all just more evidence
that this is a religion
in this in the same way that when you
had failing public schools
in the past and even today in other
parts of the country
sometimes you would get students
enrolling in catholic schools because
the catholic schools were relatively
pretty good so you get all sorts of
students who weren't catholic
necessarily who'd say yeah well my kid's
not catholic but i'm going to send them
to the catholic school because it's got
better academic standards
well now as the catholic schools are
under attack you now have
lgbt schools
a school
designed for the promotion of lgbt
ideology and you've got the straight
kids going because they say well look
i'm my kid might not be lgbt yet but i
i'm going to send my kid there to that
school because it's better than the
public schools
and of course it's a religion i mean if
you if you say
your true self is really this your soul
and your soul is at odds with your body
and so your soul is the soul of a woman
whatever that means but your body is the
body of a man and so you're really a
woman and you're going to get to use the
kid's bathroom
that is a religious
movement and it's being backed by the
state with taxpayer dollars the biden
administration we'll get to this
tomorrow the biden administration has
just said that k-12 schools now have to
let let dudes into the girls bathroom
and changing area if they want to get
federal funds for food for lunches and
breakfasts and meals they want those
federal funds sorry you got to let husky
hank go and change next to your daughter
in the locker room or go use the
bathroom
that is a religious view that is being
backed by the state
it's very nearly as a state
establishment at the federal level it's
being done with your taxpayer dollars to
force that on your kids and it's
creating a very dangerous situation for
our culture and in the case of dudes
going to the girls bathroom just a
physically very dangerous situation
reminds us of our prime not our primary
but one of our primary obligations that
we have in a society and it's a duty and
it's an obligation and it's a right
regardless of what joe biden or any of
these other idiots want you to believe
that is the duty and the right to
protect yourself and your family and
your community i'm glad you like that
clip now you got a ring
ding subscribe smash like whatever you
got to do get the notifications for the
michael knowles show head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]